resuelve la ecuación x cuadrada menos
equis cuadrada menos 4 / x2 igual a 4
con la restricción de que x no puede ser
igual a 2 porque no puede ser igual a 2
porque si x fuera igual a 2 esta
fracción esta expresión racional estaría
indeterminada porque estaríamos
dividiendo entre 0 entonces pues porque
nos encontramos que el valor de x
satisface esta ecuación o sea resolvemos
la ecuación y bueno hay muchas formas de
hacerlo de hecho lo primero que se te
puede ocurrir es decir ok vamos a tomar
este x al cuadrado y multiplicarlo por x
menos 2 entre x menos 2 para que tengan
el mismo denominador y poder sumarlo con
esto pero como siempre hay un camino más
fácil que otro y ahorita por lo menos a
mí y seguramente a ti también si has
hecho los ejercicios de diferencias de
cuadrados
este numerador de aquí es una diferencia
de cuadrados y además no es cualquier
diferencia de cuadrados es una muy
conveniente
es x2 x x2 entonces podríamos cancelar
ese x2 con el denominador y nos quedaría
algo muy sencillo no entonces pues
propongo que hagamos paso por paso
volviendo a escribir esto tenemos que x
cuadrado menos y aquí en lugar de
escribir x al cuadrado menos 4 vamos a
escribir x + 2
por equis menos 2 baja porque la
multiplicación de estos dos es igual a
esto y en el denominador tenemos x menos
2 y todo esto tiene que ser igual a 4 y
estamos asumiendo y vamos a asumir a lo
largo del resto del vídeo que x tiene
que ser distinto de 2 pero por el
momento justo como x es distinto de 2
entonces esto de aquí es distinto de 0 y
por lo tanto esto entre esto es igual a
1 y entonces nos queda simplemente x + 2
por el 1 que representan estos dos
aunque entonces podemos tachar los y nos
queda simplemente x cuadrada menos
2 igual a 4 aunque entonces lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es distribuir este
signo menos dentro de este paréntesis
así es que nos queda x cuadrado menos x
menos 2 igual a 4 y aquí lo que queremos
hacer es modificar esta ecuación para
que nos quedó de la forma a x cuadrada
más bx más e igual a cero ok cero porque
entonces podemos factorizar este lado o
utilizar la fórmula de la ecuación
cuadrática que algunos los llaman la
chicharronera o cualquier otro tipo de
técnica que tengamos para resolver
ecuaciones de segundo grado que el
chiste es que queremos dejar aquí un
cero y la mejor forma de hacerlo es
restar cuatro de los dos lados del igual
así es que nos queda
x cuadrada menos x menos 6 igual a cero
entonces déjame le escribo por aquí
tenemos aquí x menos x menos 6 es igual
a cero estamos asumiendo también que x
es distinto de 2 pero bueno el chiste es
que este polinomio se ve como que lo
podemos factorizar fácilmente no o sea
el 6 no tiene tantos factores el chiste
es que buscamos dos números tales que si
ponemos aquí x x
y esto se va a ser igual a cero entonces
buscamos dos números que es sumar aquí
de tal forma que este número por este
número nos quede menos 6 y como tenemos
aquí un menos entonces estos dos
símbolos van a ser distintos así que
aquí tenemos un más algo y un menos algo
y además estos dos números con todo y su
signo a la hora de sumarlos nos tiene
que quedar menos x entonces pensemos yo
digo que es menos 3 y más dos que hay
dos por menos 3 es menos 6 y 2 más menos
3 es menos 1 ya está así es la
factorización de este polinomio aunque
entonces ya que tenemos este polinomio
factor izado de esta forma ahora sabemos
que hay únicamente dos formas en las que
esta multiplicación podría ser igual a
cero y eso es que este paréntesis sea
igual a cero o que este otro paréntesis
sea igual a cero
ok tenemos aquí x
2 es igual a cero x menos tres es igual
a cero
ahora x más 12 es igual a cero si y sólo
si x es igual a menos 2 y x menos tres
es igual a cero sí solo si x es igual a
3 entonces este polinomio es igual a 0
si x es igual al menos 2 o x es igual a
3 ok entonces las x que satisfacen esta
ecuación que la resuelven son menos 2 y
3 pero sería muy bueno verificar nuestra
respuesta entonces empecemos por
verificar si x igual a menos 2 en efecto
si satisface esta ecuación para hacerlo
tenemos que sustituir x igual a menos 2
en la ecuación y de eso tenemos menos 2
al cuadrado que está x al cuadrado menos
x cuadrada que es otra vez menos 2 al
cuadrado menos cuatro menos 4 y luego
aquí tenemos x menos 2 que es menos dos
menos dos y tenemos que verificar que
todas estas cuentas sean igual a cuatro
porque si son igual a cuatro entonces
está x si satisface esta ecuación si es
que veamos menos dos al cuadrado eso es
un 4 menos menos dos al cuadrado eso es
un 4 menos 4 menos 4 y aquí tenemos
menos dos menos 2 que es menos 4 pero
aquí tenemos 4 menos 4 y todo esto es un
cero así es que todo esto de aquí no nos
importa porque es simplemente un cero y
esto es simplemente 4 -0 que si es igual
a 4 así es que si x igual a menos 2 si
satisface la ecuación muy bien
vamos a chequear si x igual a 3 también
satisface esta ecuación y para hacerlo
pues vamos a sustituir x igual a 3
entonces tenemos x cuadrada que es
es al cuadrado - x cuadrada que es otra
vez 3 al cuadrado menos 4 / x menos 2
que es 3 - 2 ok y queremos verificar si
eso es igual a 4 entonces 3 al cuadrado
es 9 menos 3 al cuadrado es 9 menos
cuatro menos 4 y aquí tres menos 2 es un
1 así es que podemos poner esto entre
paréntesis y borrar esto porque
cualquier cosa entre 1 es esa misma cosa
y entonces aquí tenemos nueve menos
nueve que 0 y luego menos menos cuatro
que simplemente 4
así es que esto también es igual a 4 y
entonces x igual a 3 también satisface
esta ecuación de estos dos valores son
solución a esta ecuación